[Applause]
[Music]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lay
higher pen show powered by icon plus
capital the vc firm and it is sponsored
by block five so i've left a link
somewhere um i think in the description
and in the comments so if you like you
can take a look and they offer a really
cool interest rate so definitely hit on
that and um yeah really great interest
rates i think you also get around um i
think about six percent on your bitcoin
so really really interesting there so
joining me today we have a very exciting
guest somebody who i've spoken to a few
times and every single time i speak to
him i'm always learning more it's the
founder ceo cio of morgan creek capital
management it is mark yusko mark great
to see you how are you doing today
can you hear me mark
okay maybe you cannot hear me are we
having a technical issue
mark can you hear me
okay guys let me know in the comments if
you can hear me or not um
maybe
i don't know if it's me or if it's mark
let's have a look
i think my mic seems to be working
mark can you hear me
i don't know
i don't know if it's me okay guys can
you let me know in the comments if it's
me or if it's mark i don't know
marcus frozen
hey how's that
yes can you hear me i can i can't oh
cool i don't know what happened i there
was a button i needed to push so i
pushed the button and now we're live oh
perfect well welcome to the show how are
you mark i'm doing great doing great
thanks for having me back and uh great
to see you
yeah it's a pleasure i'm always learning
so much from you um i think we first
spoke back in maybe 2018 or 2019 and
we're talking about gold and bitcoin and
you know whether it really can replace
it so we're going to get into all of
that but i do want to start off with um
going through some of the latest
headlines because it's been a crazy week
unfortunately
things are down china's back in the news
um i want to talk about evergrand
i'm sorry to bring it up i know i know
it's not the best topic everybody
is very emotional right now but
i think it's unclear what necessarily
happened and i really like your
explanation breaking down what happened
and why there's been such a spillover
into the crypto markets people often
think you know bitcoin is um not
connected and you know not affected by
these things but can you break it down
for us what exactly happened yeah well
everything's
interrelated in in
in some ways right i mean nothing is is
fully independent of global capital
flows
and look the evergrand story is
is interesting in in so many ways i mean
one
it is
uh
kind of the epitome of the rags to
riches story that that happened in china
you know you had
uh this this process over over a long
time 30 years
of basically dragging you know the
population of the us and europe put
together
out of abject poverty into middle class
and in order to do that you had to build
four cities the size of philadelphia
every year
you just just think about that right i
mean just
building four cities the size of
philadelphia every single year and the
only way to really do that was to have
shall we say captive companies and so
companies like evergrand were property
developers and they were very well
connected and they had access to a
couple things
really cheap land basically grants from
from very powerful people
uh they had access to cheap financing
and so the leverage ratios were high and
they built out much of
the
you know apartment buildings and
complexes and things that that we saw
now it would have been
fine i guess if you stop there but but
as these companies grow they become
uh involved in other financial services
uh and as as fate would have it we have
some cycles in the market
and we had the big uh
problem with the global financial crisis
and again making a long long long story
short
they used the financial services
infrastructure of china to raise capital
to essentially
you know uh booster their balance sheet
and so
those
products those financial products were
sold through the you know or to the
masses
and people thought they were getting
access to to great you know long-term
investment property
um but as we know and
i think you know i've talked about this
in the past but leverage
can never make a bad investment good
right but it can actually make a good
investment bad if you're forced to sell
an asset at the wrong time that can put
a lot of pressure on on price
and the problem is once
you get the margin call
if you can't go back and raise capital
you've gone to the well too many times
which is the case here
um
and maybe you
made somebody angry
in the politburo or or maybe
the whole
movement at the highest levels of
government in china changed to this idea
of you know equilibration of the classes
right let's take some
from the top
uh and and push it down the social
prosperity thing so
i think all of those factors came into
play and
and it wasn't just evergrand right
there's a whole bunch of property
developers
equity is basically trending towards
zero uh they still have assets and those
assets in many cases are still pretty
good
the reason crypto gets involved is
if you're prone to speculate
and um it's a problem in asia and a lot
of gambling and uh you take macau for
example that makes vegas look like you
know a church gathering
um
so prone to gambling prone to
speculation so you speculate in a few
condos that you lever up then you might
speculate in stocks and lever up because
you know margin debt is is cheap but the
real problem was in crypto right in
crypto you bet not five times leverage
or ten times leverage or 20 times
leverage you get a hundred times
leverage or 125 times leverage
and
again just do the math right if you're
100 times leverage a one percent move
wipes out your equity
you're talking about take bitcoin an 80
vol asset
100 times leverage on an 80 vol asset
means you will
lose your bitcoin
and i i'd somebody call me and say you
know they stole my bitcoin said nope no
one stole your bitcoin you
made a dumb decision to lever up a
hundred to one and you
lost your bitcoin
they didn't steal it
now i will say there is an alternative
view which is
if the lender
if i'm giving you if i'm giving you a
loan out of the goodness of my heart
because i think you know you're a really
good investor and i want to back you
yeah okay
however if my goal
is to give you excessive leverage
so that i can actually
take the collateral
that's a little sinister and i'm not
saying anybody did that but i'm saying
that is another way to look at it that
maybe it wasn't all out of the goodness
of their heart maybe there was
some plan to accumulate
uh crypto assets that way so who knows
but
it's all interrelated and and once
leverage starts to unravel
it can get ugly really really fast and i
think that's what we're seeing right now
so people obviously enjoy leverage
trading particularly in crypto so is
there anything people can do to i guess
protect against something like this i
mean either you're very good at spotting
when something's happening like
evergrand and you know there's way too
many too much leverage too many risks um
or you just don't trade with a 100x
average never ever trade anything with
100x i mean that that just pretty much
rule of thumb unless you're a government
right if you're a government or a
government-sponsored entity like an
investment bank where you're too big to
fail and no matter what you lose you
will get bailed out and think of a
global financial crisis there were
plenty of firms lehman and others that
were 40 80 100 times levered
no one went to jail in fact we bailed
them out
it's it's unfathomable but for for the
individual
don't don't do it and no matter how
easy it seems
uh and even if you win early
you will lose right it's it's kind of
like the the winner's curse you go to a
casino
and you you place a bet
and you win
it's the worst possible thing that could
happen because now you will stay
and lose all your money and then you'll
go to the atm and take out more and try
to win it back and then you lose more
the best thing is you you take a certain
amount you play and you have some fun
and you have a couple drinks
and you lose it by the end of the night
that's really good but if you win early
you'll think you have skill and the odds
are not in your favor so
levered look
investing
buying assets below their value and
holding them for the long term
it's a really good thing everybody
should do it trading where you're trying
to buy assets because they're moving and
selling to someone else before they stop
moving
tougher
some people are good at it not for me
some people get at out
speculating right buying something that
you have no knowledge of
and and doing it just because it's
moving
you'll you'll get wrecked but the worst
is just degenerate gambling right if
you're literally
playing a game where the odds
are not in your favor i mean literally
russian roulette odds don't be surprised
if you know
you shoot yourself in the head
so
put very well um i like the use of
degenerate gambling particularly in in
this industry we see a lot of it um but
i want to stick on china for the minute
because
we've seen another crackdown another
band so in your opinion how serious is
this i know there's that joke that every
year um china bans bitcoin um but
obviously not not every year sorry
2017 2021 so it is every four years
whether we need it or not they're gonna
be this one's real right now and why do
i say that well in 2013
they kind of
mouthed it
they didn't do anything about it they
just kind of said it
there were no teeth and and really it
was a very short correction and and
we're off to the races 2017
they kind of meant it right i mean
they literally said exchanges you're not
welcome here go away
and
the prices went down 40
over two weeks
uh after the the original announcement
in february
and they didn't recover
for
you know a while
and it was it took you know japan and
south korea say bring it we'll take the
exchanges love it we can tax them we can
partner with them
and and i think that was
china basically saying look we're
playing the long game
and you know here's the problem the
problem with china is china's very
misunderstood
everyone thinks
they're bad and they're evil and you
know we paint the picture of them here
in the u.s is like this adversary
china's playing a whole different game i
tweet about this right china playing go
we're arguing about how to set up
checkerboard we're playing an old game
using tariffs from the 1930s
they're playing go they're playing a
totally different game there are leagues
ahead miles ahead on the uh
almost ready to launch the e-rem and b
the e-rem and b is why they're doing
this right they
want to have control of their currency
as as does every other central
government
and
here's the interesting thing
overly indebted governments
have done this since the beginning of
time what do i mean by this meaning use
regulation
and use threat of punishment to stop
innovation
i mean go go back to the 1930s and in
the depression in the united states it
was criminal it was made a criminal
offense to own gold
why
well because gold
was money is money gold is money gold is
the only asset in the world that is
money
meaning
it exists in the absence of a liability
everything else is credit every other
currency in the world has an associated
government debt associated with it so
the only money
and it's worked for 5 000 years is gold
now
bitcoin
arguably depending on who you believe is
digital gold i actually ascribe to that
it's the perfect substitute it's a
scarce asset in digital form it's more
portable it's more divisible
has all the function doesn't have an
associated liability it's borderless
nation stateless so i think it does take
that place so just like the united
states made it criminal made it illegal
for a citizen to own gold so for 40
years in the united states it was
illegal to own gold
now did people own gold of course they
did
but
they did
confiscate gold from some people they
incarcerated some people and i had this
debate with my partners this morning
they're like no chance no chance you
know the united states follows and does
this
maybe maybe not and and how do they
enforce it it's not seasonal i said well
here's the thing
put yourself in this situation
you're arrested
you're locked in solitary confinement
give up your private key i'll let you
out
who does that who doesn't do that i
don't know i might give up my private
key if it means total loss of liberty or
give up my private key
i might i'm not saying i would and now
i'm going to do i understand you know
for saying oh you know you're not going
to go down with the ship i'm like well
it depends
so it depends how painful that ship is
right how destructive that ship is
governments have tools
to to enforce i know they can't seize
right they can't hack into the
blockchain and take your your bitcoin
but they can
make life difficult and that's what
china's doing because china
absolutely positively is playing a
different game
they are miles ahead they know exactly
what they want to do to create this belt
and road initiative which is the
recreation of the silk road they are
creating trade routes
and uh a community to pull the center of
the universe back to where it was for
eighteen hundred last two thousand years
for eighteen hundred of the last two
thousand years the center of the
universe was squarely in china then it
moved to europe for 100 years and now
it's been in the u.s for 100 years it's
going back to china there's nothing
anybody can do about it
now no one wants to believe that nobody
wants to think that they're capable of
it
but they're really smart really highly
educated and they
are doing the things that at least looks
to me that you would do if that was your
plan
so there's so much going on here because
the way that you know you talk about
china saying that you know they're
playing go and they're well ahead of us
um that sort of to me implies that we
should therefore be doing what china are
doing especially if we're if especially
in your opinion if we're going back to
china being the center of everything but
that would then imply that we being the
west the uk the usa needs to do the same
and also crack down on
cryptocurrency regulations so that leads
me to my next bit
the infrastructure bill and just
generally you know with all these issues
with the sec what is and what isn't a
security
where are we going with this
people are concerned
and should be concerned you should
people should be afraid and they should
they should be legitimately afraid
there are a couple things right one
incumbents
have used regulation
to beat back disruptors
forever
right whether it was the you know
buggy whip manufacturers and the street
sweepers at the turn of the century that
you know paid the lobbyists to put up
regulation to make it hard for horseless
carriages to come into new york city or
whether it was the train companies
lobbying to make it hard for airlines
and airports to get built because they
didn't want people using air airlines
whether it was net neutrality around you
know telcos whether it was cable versus
terrestrial television whether it's
satellites and trying to limit the
numbers out
incumbents will always use regulation
because it can be paid for you know i
love
americans
we're great right we have this american
exceptionalism and oh all you other
countries you're corrupt china's worked
russia's corrupt india is corrupt
what is lobbying
that is corruption that
plain and simple it's corruption i mean
i used my favorite example exxon mobil
2013. they made 40 billion dollars
of profit how much should they pay in
tax 40 tax rate back then they should
have paid 16 billion well they lobbied
327 million dollars that year
highest in washington and what was their
tax bill
minus 1.8 billion they actually got a
refund
that's one of the great investments of
all time you turned 327 million into you
know 58 billion in
uh
i mean and set into 17 17.8 billion in
in a year awesome so
lobbying is is real and what the banks
are doing right now right i believe
personal opinion i think the banks
are playing
hot and heavy with the regulators
and
putting up
hurdles
they're not on barriers they're not you
know barbed wire fences with razor wire
but they're hurdles
for
you know the block fives and you know
one of our biggest investments and
and you know brian armstrong is going at
it with
goldman gary um and that's the thing
look
jay clayton
uh you know i thought he actually did a
really good job he was measured he was
prudent someone said he was too slow and
he didn't pass the etf but
at least we knew the sec was going to be
consistent in their regulation
right now the rhetoric has
strengthened and it appears
that
maybe the
the the roots or the connections to to
the banks because the banks are big
losers here and
if you noticed on friday
there were 10 organizations in china
that
all said the same thing right we're
making this illegal but who
was the spokesperson
the bank of china why
because the bank of china has an over
levered banking system that cannot
survive if deposits funnel out of it
into things like alipay and
you know crypto and so they cracked down
on ant financial and ollie pay because
they signed 90 billion dollars out of
the banking system says you can't do
that anymore
now they're saying we don't want any
more to leave into crypto because that
will [ __ ] the banks even more than
they're already crippled and i think the
same things happen in the united states
where
these big banks are like wait a second
we don't want
our deposits because if i if i put my
money in the bank i get paid zero
yeah take that fiat convert it into
crypto deposit it at blockfy or anybody
else and get paid
why wouldn't i do that i do do that i
think that's awesome but the bank
doesn't like that because now their
deposit base shrinks
maybe the loans aren't as good in if the
economy's not going to grow as much and
with demographics as bad as they are
we're certainly not going to grow like
we used to because we don't have any
working age population growth
and we got a baby bust so we have all
kinds of challenges for economic growth
loan growth
banking growth
and if everybody takes a portion of
their wealth and opts out
yeah
you get to then
yeah absolutely but
practically speaking i'd really like to
understand where you
see let's say in the next 10 years this
industry with you know from what i can
see
regulation is heating up everything is
heating up you know the more um this
this industry expands you know not just
bitcoin but defy and everything that's
going on
you know you said we should be worried
how are you no no look first they ignore
you then they laugh at you then they
fight you then you win
okay so
when they were ignoring us you know 2009
to 2015
and everybody's partying and having fun
and and developing and it was just a
bunch of nerds and you know just kind of
no one cared it was a tiny science
experiment
2015 like oh wait a minute that's no
longer a science experiment ah that's
just that's a ponzi scheme ah ha ha ha
you guys again you're just nerds you
don't know anything we're we're finance
we're banks we you know we're in charge
2021.
now it's a fight and
2013 not a fight right that's yep yeah
whatever we're banning you
dumb little game but you're you know
we're not gonna do it 2017
we're banning you because you're stupid
it's just a stupid little game right
this time
we're banning you because you're a
threat
of course now
name a technology
that
had to overcome
uh this type of regulatory pressure
uh
you know shaming in the in the press you
know the internet even facebook i
wouldn't say even facebook everything i
mean they had that day dynamic
technology that went back in the bottle
right that they put the genie back in
the bottle you can't do it there's no
way
because it's it's it's a better form
of ownership and what we're talking
about here is not just bitcoin not just
ethereum not just money we're basically
talking about
value
yeah
the internet made information flow two
way
right just like the printing press
unlocked the lock of power by the church
you know then we had the internet kind
of unlock the power of of government we
became a little bit more democratized
around the world accessed information
and
people could you know
gig economy and lots of good things have
come out of that and basically the media
business and the commerce business
got totally disrupted
but remember mom and pop shop owners
didn't like this and they lobbied hard
and and the cable tv companies didn't
like this so they lobbied hard to stop
streaming but now everybody streams no
one has cable and not no one but
um the same thing is is true here
eventually the technology
wins
but this this fight phase will be
unpleasant and it'll be volatile
and it will cause
stress and yeah and it really depends
how much it escalates right if you think
about
you know
uh
the war over
transportation right the railroads when
they were
member i think it was king leopold said
why would anyone pay
ever many pence to to go across europe
in an hour when they could easily take
their horse in a day for free
um an hour versus convenience rather i
don't know oh gee yeah yeah it would be
more efficient and and then train tracks
but think about you know they had to go
through people's land and they had to
get right away and they had to do
eminent domain and
and there were a whole bunch of people
who got really really rich right i mean
i live in north carolina the flagler
family basically owned the east coast of
the united states because they built the
railroad from new york to florida
and so
that same process is happening now it's
just it's not railroads and it's not
you know terrestrial television or or
video games it is
value
value over internet protocol i believe
is the most important innovation of this
century it will create untold wealth
the problem is it's not going to be
linear it's actually going to be
parabolic
but it's not even going to be smooth
it's going to be choppy and wavy
and fits and starts but once we start
into the parabolic phase which hadn't
really started yet
it was funny i am i was been talking and
i was saying you know it's it's like
they just finished the national anthem
right they haven't even started the game
and i was up in new york at this
conference and the guy said no mark
the players haven't even entered the
stadium yet that's how early it is
do you have a time frame like where does
the match start
look where are we
i've been talking about this for a long
time that yeah we're at this 14-year
technological cycle it has to do with
computing power and start with the
mainframe in 54 and the microchip in 68
the personal computer and 82 and the
internet in 96 the mobile net in 2010
and the trust net
in 2024
so we're still two years
away from that that's like the beginning
of the game
then what happens is four years in
you have a crash
so if you go back to 54 there's a crash
in 58 you're right 68 there's crash in
72 73. you go back to 96 there's a crash
in 2000. you go to 2010 there's a crash
in 1415. so
so we've got two years to kind of build
we got to get through this
kind of nonsense of the regulatory
hurdles and the the fud the fear and
certainty and doubt and all that
incumbents not wanting it to happen
then we'll have the aha moment where
everybody will say oh of course it's so
clear blockchain technology is the
operating system for the internet of
value oh we call it trust net okay cool
then
we'll all get excited valuations will go
parabolic
and then it won't all work
and it'll bust
and i use pets.com right pets.com
okay gonna be this big company they're
gonna deliver food using the internet
for your pet
it is the epitome of the failure of the
internet
chewy.com
i get a box from them every week it's
the same company
it's the exact same company same idea
same everything it just took 21 years
to mature netflix
almost went bankrupt twice
before it went parabolic all of the big
wealth in web 2
was created after
the bust remember when the internet was
going to cease to exist all the
naysayers see i told you that the
internet was no more well it was this
because i was probably just born 2000
2001. yeah i mean it was
when everybody said like
you know paul krugman famously said
in 96 i think 97. the internet will
never be more important than the fax
machine
i really i mean
get it that wrong my gosh but and
it was labeled a fad and it was labeled
you know something that rot rots the
brains of young people and yeah and
there's there's no use case
and
i think basically
anytime something's labeled a fad
you should buy it
by both hands lock it in a drawer don't
look at it because the problem is if you
look at it you'll sell it
right like amazon went down twice 90 and
people sold the only people that bought
amazon when it went public and held to
today i said jeff his mom his dad and
his ex-wife that's it everybody else
sold because of the volatility
and and the same thing is going to
happen here whether it's d5 and look we
haven't even talked good enough time but
we could talk we could spend
all day today and all day tomorrow and
the rest of the week just sitting here
talking which would be very pleasant for
me but no we could do it and we wouldn't
even scratch the surface of play to earn
of the metaverse
uh well before yeah
i do want to i do want to just like talk
about this this period of uncertainty
because we have cbdc's which are on the
rise you know you mentioned the digital
yuan um you know the uk are talking
about the e-pound or even brit coin
which just makes my ears cry um so where
do you stand on cbdc's i personally hate
them with every part every bone in my
body um that's just me as you should
right i mean yeah they suffer all
of the defects
yeah any
asset that's created by a monopoly okay
so you know so they start from a bad
place
then on top of that
they're basically
fiat
which
is designed right fiat currency
currency that is not backed by a hard
commodity
is designed to steal wealth from the
masses and give it to the rich
that's it right
the rothschilds invented it in the 1600s
and the you know the bank of england
came a couple couple hundred years later
and bank of spain and and then you know
the fed in 1913
central banks were created
to steal the wealth from the masses
don't
don't confuse it with you know economic
stability it is theft it is kleptocracy
now that said
a central bank digital currency
makes it worse
why
well right now
they can the central banks through
manipulation of interest rates
can
push something called financial
repression so in europe or japan you
have negative interest rates right
you have to put your money in the bank
and you have to pay them to hold it so
there's no incentive to save there's an
incentive to take your money out and
either invest it in risky assets or what
they really want to do is spend it to
create economic activity why because the
people in charge
pale mail and stale right
have
promised through entitlements which the
definition of an entitlement it's a
promise you make to yourself that you
don't fund that you ask your kids to pay
for
right my mom believes that there's a
little pot of money in washington dc
called judy's money
okay like mom there's no pot so what do
you mean i i paid in all this money all
these years i'm like yeah and it got
spent right now
my money
goes in for taxes and pays you
but here's the problem when they set it
up in the 1930s there were 17 workers
for every retiree
really good system
when i reach retirement age
right there'll be two so i was used to
saying i lose because my kids would give
it to my wife not me so i had to have a
third kid didn't have the fourth but i
had the third so i'm half taken care of
and so
the reality is
that
that process
is
is a forced form of compliance
but you can still opt out right i can
leave my money in the bank and i can
accept the negative interest rate or the
low interest rate
or the loss of wealth through inflation
with a central bank digital currency
holy freaking crap
it's scary what they can do
they can program
that
if you don't use this money by the end
of the month
it is
if you
you because your social score is so low
you can't spend on this fancy car you
can't spend on this piece of art you
can't buy this other digital asset you
because we think less of you can only
buy these certain things we can program
the money
we
can surveil everything you do with your
money
right
no longer
you know can i hand somebody money or
send somebody money
gone
all of that
is bad and i can probably get over it
except for the fact
that
i have a small margin of safety
the average person doesn't have a margin
of safety
and that's insane to think that someone
works hard
like i have this experience i flew
through chicago to go to a football game
this weekend right and as i'm coming out
of the airport i always look at the
price
to park
for one day
at o'hare airport
okay how much to park for one day is
like 75
that's two days
maybe actually now three days
of minimum wage after tax earnings
to park for one day well they don't park
there they get dropped off but that's
not my point my point is
that's insane and now
if that person works really hard to make
that 75
if the central bank can turn on a switch
and say boy you know if you don't spend
it at a restaurant or at the gap
i'm sorry it's no longer your money
that is a frightening frightening
thought so
for all those reasons i'm i'm in your
camp i i i can't stand the idea of
central bank digital currencies to the
core of my being but they're coming
the chinese will be first the russians
will be second
we
because we're stupid and we're not doing
anything
we'll be third or fourth or fifth well
do you think you should be first
should you be first if you know people
don't like it
well
it's all evil but if you're gonna be and
you'll be first and evil because here's
the reason that you don't want to be
second or third the dollar
today is
the evil currency right is it is the
hegemonic world reserve currency because
we cut a deal with saudi in 71 said
we'll protect you if you denominate all
transactions globally in dollars so
think about this anyone who challenged
that disappeared saddam hussein i'm
going to price oil in euros gone gaddafi
i'm gonna price oil and gold gone anyone
who ever threatens
the denomination of petrol transactions
in dollars wiped out okay that's what
all the wars are about all of it
now
if you are in venezuela
and the dictator comes in gets all his
cronies pushes all the assets to the
cronies and then wipes out the value of
the currency so their assets skyrocket
people forget the best performing stock
market in the world the last three years
is venezuela
did you want to own any venezuelan
stocks no
because you have to live there which
actually is not a bad place but you have
to live there own the venezuelan stocks
to get the benefit and you have to be
part of
the the top but if you're an average
person in venezuela you got wiped out
because the bolivar went down 99.999
so what if you had opted out
what did you do you actually went out in
the street and you tried to buy dollars
that was the first thing you did you
tried to buy green pieces of paper now
sometimes they were counterfeit
sometimes they're real but that's what
you did well then people said well hey
you could use this thing called dash so
let's use dash has done really well and
then we're like hey you could buy some
bitcoin
now mostly it's local bitcoins where you
got to meet the guy or the gal in the
alley and you got to swap and there's a
wrench risk and all kinds of bad stuff
and
but people did it and they saved some of
their wealth
so
i think about
all of these places where
uh the governments
are
again intentionally devaluing their
currencies to push the wealth up to the
top of the food chain
all of what we're all working on now in
crypto is to prevent that and so
that's why at the end of the day
uh oh so my point on china china said no
no here we'll give you the e-rem and b
just buy the e-rem and b and we'll honor
it and we'll take care of you
so then what happens is the dollar
starts to lose ground as the global war
reserve currency
so that's why i think we should have
been there faster because if people
wanted to buy
something beside their home currency
why not make it an e-dollar
or a fed i wouldn't call it a fed dollar
called an e-dollar but um
by the way you know you know where the
dollar the word comes from
well
from the netherlands
from the rothschilds the rothschilds set
up the first central bank in the
netherlands and theirs was called the
dolar so we stole it because we admired
their
thievery i guess
and uh now we have dollars
i think that the whole idea of cbdc is
absolutely frightened me and we have
that margin like you said that's that's
that safety margin and i think if it
wasn't for bitcoin i would be absolutely
petrified like i always refer to myself
as just like awake and i'm just like
watching everything that's going on um
we don't need to i'm not gonna get
political for another time uh i mean we
could do but i won't throw that on you
right we don't even have to get
political because it's all the same
all the same but i say this all time
there's no left there's no right there's
no democrats or republicans or labor or
concern it's in
and out
and when you're out you do or say
whatever it takes to get in and when
you're in you do or say whatever it
takes to stay in so all this different
no they're all the same they're all
after the same thing
power and money and it and it's all
about moving it to the top because we
live in a hierarchical world
now the the problem again
is technology
has now found a way to invert the
pyramid
and they don't like that and that's why
a lot of people are going to do a lot of
things to try to stop
this but
i remember who said it to me the first
time but think about if you get lost
right do you stop and ask for directions
no especially not where i live in the
south because they say well go to where
the old store used to be take a left and
then go to where the oak tree was and
take a right i'm like
i don't know where those are i haven't
been here for 20 years so you're telling
me
now i look at google maps or apple maps
and i just go
and 99 of time it works but
in code we trust so now you have the
ability to have
smart contracts and we have the ability
to have derivative contracts that can't
be spoofed by bankers in london
who then get fined and they're like oh
well we build the fines into our
business because it's just part of doing
business so yeah we know we're cheating
and we're suppressing the price of gold
but that's what we do
in a smart contract you can't do that
and so
code
equalizes
the top and the bottom
and the bottom
get power and jimmy song talks about
this so beautifully he said look if you
get
a fixed income right either you know
you're on fixed income as a bond or a
pension or if you you know you have a
job and you get paid a wage you're a
slave
yes a strong word politically charged
but says you're a slave because
you don't control the value that that
creates because they can
deflate it away i mean inflate it away
it says with bitcoin
you
become self-sovereign and you become
able to save in a positive way
like i i haven't gotten my block fi
uh credit card yet because i'm just too
lazy to fill out the stupid i mean you
know it's like the cobbler's kid have no
shoes so
so and part of his i love my you know
american airlines credit card
but i shouldn't
because every time i accumulate all my
miles i go to spend them and they're
like oh did we say twenty thousand per
ticket no it's forty or sixty or it's
eighty so they devalue my asset
so imagine having an asset like a
bitcoin rewards card where the asset
actually increases in value but what if
it doesn't like think about it well
scarce asset
rising demand
limited supply okay i i was not
a a plus student but i got
interested in economics
if supply is fixed and demand rises and
it doesn't have to rise
off the charts it just has to keep
rising
price faster than inflation has got to
keep rising yeah so anyway
but um
okay so
a lot of a lot of different things there
and i think what's really interesting is
the whole idea of being a slave
to your employer that resonates with me
so much and it's not just about
inflation and it's not just about um you
know not being able to turn around and
say well hang on my salary isn't going
as fast as inflation is going um it's
also just about like the whole idea of
trading time for dollars and you know
just just taking ownership of your time
like the whole idea of sovereignty i'm
trying to um
bring that ethos into my life in general
not just with money but just with
everything like i want to be sovereign
over my time over everything that i do
and i think that's also what i love
about crypto and bitcoin that it doesn't
it doesn't just teach you about money it
teaches you once you you grasp the
concept of money and
sovereignty and autonomy
it then changes your opinion on
everything and the way you look at
everything 100
and i talk about something everything we
do
is about converting energy to value yes
right you and i we got up this morning
we put some fuel in our body and we go
about our day trying to convert energy
into value
and you know bitcoin is one of those
perfect
vehicles for turning energy into value
and it's a perfect store
of that value
because it can't be inflated away by by
fiat
and there are a lot of ways you can
create value in the world i mean you
could make stuff right assemble widgets
you could entertain others
you could you know create new algorithms
uh that that create value in the future
you could innovate new technologies
um you could make an old technology new
again i mean people forget all the time
they're like oh elon musk invented the
electric car no it didn't the largest
car company in america in 1903 was the
american electric vehicle company
right and henry ford put him out of
business because he wanted people to buy
his cars that ran on kerosene or or
gasoline which is an effluent of
kerosene that john d rockefeller wanted
to sell rather than flush down the river
and have the river catch on fire
and so
you know that was dormant technology for
the better part of a hundred years
before they said oh we
should
have vehicles where
we don't
make the power
on site right internal combustion engine
means every car
is its own power plant how about if we
have a
combined power plant and then we
distribute the energy and store it
interesting concept but again not new
right there's a car in the basement of
dartmouth engineering school that went
46 miles to the charge back in 1903.
pretty cool
it is and i i do want to move on just a
little bit um and i want to talk about
investments and really just spotting
that
investment because
like you said i guess actually it's not
really moving on that much because you
know you said not everything new is
necessarily new right like the electric
car so given that right now we are still
so early as everybody likes to say we
have you know um nfts booming
how are you spotting a good investment
because i understand that's what you
said you know that is where true wealth
is is built from being super early the
the greatest wealth comes from investing
in something you believe in before
others even understand it yeah well how
do you believe in it well
you have to be exposed to it okay so how
do you get exposed to new ideas
hang out with really smart people
and and make it a point to
you know look for new ideas
you know i say all the time i have the
greatest job in the world i get paid
to talk to the smartest people in the
world
right that's my job right i supposed to
go around and talk to people in hedge
funds and private equity and venture
capital and entrepreneurs and
and some of these people are just really
really really incredible
and if you can't pick up a thing or two
then you know you're just fast asleep so
one is just hang out with the right
people yeah i understand when i tell
young people you know think of the four
people you spend the most time with
that's who you'll become choose wisely
so we should all constantly be thinking
about who we want to hang out with and
who we want to spend our time with
but but in terms of spotting investment
ideas
um
very few
almost zero
are
oh i woke up one day with this great
idea i mean a lot of people think they
do that not very many actually do
mostly it's
uh a friend of a friend of a friend
introducing me to somebody
and
they tell me something
that is interesting so
uh
you know how did we invest in
infrastructure for the internet back in
the 90s i was working at the university
uh we went out to california for two
weeks we hung out interviewing actually
we weren't interviewing we were begging
to get in to kleiner perkins sequoia
excel
all these firms that even then were
popular but they weren't the brand names
that no one can get into so you could
you could get access
and in talking to those those guys and
gals you you heard stories about just
amazing innovation
but to be honest right when when they
told us about this company you know
called google
and the search engine right wait there
are 20 search engines why do we need 21
right there was alta vista there was web
crawler they said no no you don't
understand those do search the wrong way
we've invented a new way to do search
and and look like i was i was
one week old okay a week ago i actually
learned that you know there are 1.7
billion websites on the planet
okay 1.7 billion websites 7 billion
websites
ish
are owned by google
analysis doesn't surprise me i didn't
well here's here's why every time
you type in a question or i type a
question into google
they create a new website unless that
question's already been asked then they
just send you to that website
so
boom mind blown
indexation they don't search the entire
web think about searching the entire web
for some stupid question i ask about you
know italians football or something okay
no it just sends me to
the same question that someone's already
asked and i get the instantaneous answer
so
that
innovation
led to incredible wealth creation i you
know i always say there should be a quad
at notre dame called the google quad or
you know when
when uh we saw
uh the opportunity in the mobile net
to invest in e-commerce and we invested
in alibaba and we invested in vip shop
and and we invested in in the companies
that were
helping these companies
do the the infrastructure the
fulfillment services you know the
machines and
again it wasn't that we were geniuses it
was that we heard these incredible
entrepreneurs
and here was the funny part webb vann
which was a total failure in 2000 right
smartest guy head of arthur anderson
uh leaves starts this company huge
backing i think like seven
seven hundred i mean it was some crazy
number and they were gonna deliver stuff
to people using the internet and it
totally created total loss
doordash and
and ubereats are the same thing
we just needed broadband we needed more
delivery we needed gps
how did we get gps this is an awesome
story right so
gps
was this
system for the government right
and
they
built it literally using eminent domain
on a piece of spectrum that was owned by
this
big hedge fund
uh guy and they were going to create
this fourth network and
att and verizon and t-mobile there was
going to be this fourth one that was
going to compete and we had invested in
it
and
the two big ones through lobbying
corruption basically said we don't want
them
to compete with us so here's what here
we say
go to them and say
you know that that uh
gps system
your new network is interfering and
that's a national defense risk
of course well wait a minute
is my property you built a garage on my
property and now you're telling me that
my property interferes with your
enterprise
sounds about right about how it happened
and and so
it went bankrupt and but we needed that
gps
system so they can track us all the time
on these
um
and so all of it comes together to say
so how do you how do you pick a good
investment uh one
talk to lots and lots and lots of people
and listen to lots and lots of crazy
ideas
um
but i also say that in
much of it is just pattern recognition
you know if you've heard one story
about a 50 chance getting it right until
you think and then your odds go down if
you've heard 10 stories actually got a
little better odds because you can hear
the bad ones because they're really easy
i would say i know in five minutes i'll
never invest with somebody
my five years sometimes to figure out
five minutes though what's the red flag
in five minutes oh it's just look
there's so many right i mean there's the
no jerk rule a more fanciful term for
that but there's the no jerk rule i mean
just people who are arrogant people who
are pigheaded people who aren't
courteous and one of my big things is
right how do you treat the other people
around you
i mean people who don't treat their
peers and you know and subordinates well
no time um you know
there's things that are fanciful that
just don't sound right they sound too
big and and too grand but then there's
the stuff where you just you just listen
well it's the first time i met zach and
flory at block fight right it was just
easy i mean she's a genius he's an
amazing leader i mean together they're
magic
and
and part of it is
just you've seen it before right and
you know having white hair proves i've
been around a long enough because it is
true that old saying that which doesn't
kill you makes you stronger all the
losses
make you a better investor right all the
times you made a mistake that you
thought something was going to be great
and
um i'm a big believer also in and now
it's really popular and and i'm not
saying i was early i again it wasn't my
idea i read in business school this
paper by paul romer and paul romer won
the nobel prize three years ago for
something called the law of increasing
returns
and i read this paper as part of my you
know class and i but it just it struck
me it just it just hit me
what he said is it's not the best
technology that wins it's the technology
that gets critical mass first
and so for the rest of my career which
that's luck right why did i read that
paper luck total luck could have blown
that assignment offer like i did many
other assignments but i actually read it
and it and it just hit me that the
network effect was real and that yes it
was this getting to critical mass and
you know i remember in in 2000
whenever it was 17 right when we were
starting morgan creek digital
you know and i was getting and that was
my hashtag big really big you know
blockchain is big really big bitcoins
big really big people like you're an
idiot it's a ponzi scheme and why do you
believe in this
and and i said look it it it is
we've seen this movie before
and the miracle
was not
whether bitcoin would go from a thousand
dollars back then to four thousand
dollars or forty thousand dollars or
four hundred thousand dollars which was
my price target at the time yes
but it was that it went from
0.004
to 1
that was the miracle right it should
have died it should have been a science
experiment that failed
but it didn't and so
then you have to do the work and when
you do the work
and you realize this is innovation writ
large and eric schmidt summed it up
better than anybody else as only eric
schmidt can smart guy
from google he said look what satoshi
nakamoto whoever he she they are did is
not
that they created bitcoin okay that
that's big but that's not the big thing
the big thing
is that he she they created a way to
create
scarce assets in a digital world
because in the analog world scarcity is
easy i do a painting there's only one it
is scarce
yes if i take a picture of that and i
put into a jpeg
i can copy paste a million times it's
not scarce anymore the electronic world
had very difficult time with scarcity
yeah in the digital world now with nfts
i know chris dixon's i'm not going to
steal his thunder because he he did it i
didn't
but
he did this thread a week ago about
why nfts are so much bigger than anyone
understands because it's not about
crappy art or good art depending on your
view of art it's not about
crypto punks or
you know rare pep punks
it's about
digital scarcity yeah and that there
will be
tokens
okay whether non-fungible or whatever
just tokens there will be tokens
someday
orders of magnitude more than websites
and websites
make the internet so now we're going to
have orders of magnitude more tokens so
we can exchange anything of value every
stock every bond every currency every
commodity piece of art a piece of real
estate every case of wine
that you know that that silly piece of
art behind me right that that
my car outside everything
will be tokenized and it will live
outside borders outside nation states
that's what scares the nation states
that's what scares the governments
that's what scares the banks because now
you and i can exchange value
in a two-way transaction
without any intermediary without any
counterparty risk
without any fees no there will be fees
there will be fees like right now i can
send you bitcoin across lightning for
zero
that's the wrong number
and and we own a little piece of that
company and we're really excited uh with
strike but
with the bitcoin tipping i mean the
twitter tipping and all that
but
zero is the wrong number
right there has to be some
fee for
executing these transactions but right
now it's about growth it's about
accumulation and back to paul romer what
paul romer said is
there's a reason
that
the technology that gets the biggest
network effect wins it's because it
becomes unassailable
and people say oh but what about myspace
and and facebook michael yes now it's
even better
that was in a closed source world in an
open source world it's over
because in the closed source world i
actually could invent something better
right the technology of facebook was
superior to myspace
incrementally but it was better
now
if you
are the main coder for the bitcoin
blockchain and i want to add something
incremental you hit copy paste and
you're just as good or better so
the open source world
coupled with the metcalf's law growth
you know once something becomes the
leader it becomes unassailable and the
compounding effect
of these markets
is why i do believe this is the greatest
wealth creation opportunity i'll see in
my lifetime
i think
it's truly incredible everything is just
going digital um you answered my next
question i really wanted to hear your
thought on nfts but yeah you've
definitely answered that um
which means you've answered my question
on your thoughts on ethereum um and
everything else but just finally then
all go on did you did you know
i think ethereum
is
an amazing toolkit
i think it has some limitations and of
course i think there are other layer
ones that are you know trying to to
compete
and ultimately
i don't think we need to know right now
if you go back to the internet
there were 80
protocols there's tcpip and there was a
whole bunch of others today we have five
right we got tcp we got ftp we had http
we got smtp and we got www dot that ties
everything together
in your future
no i can see a world where bitcoin's the
base layer
where
filecoin does what ftp does
maybe it's
maybe it's solana maybe it's polka dot
that is
two layers and then ethereum is the www
dot never says oh but it doesn't scale
and it's you know look
not today tomorrow good technology
innovators will innovate and they will
solve
the problems or
someone else will solve something else
and it will gain critical mass
and you know and we'll have other
solutions but
i think
at least
right now it appears that the btc and
ethr
are the leaders
and
i look at one as a base layer
and a use case as digital gold i look at
the other as a tool kit on which other
things will be built and the benefit of
that is unlike a store of value
where
the increase in value
is determined by usage the more users
and a fixed supply the higher the value
here we have a model where we can share
right actually infinity
grossed more than fortnight in the last
12 months
it's unbelievable and part of it's owned
by the user community that's awesome and
that model will be replicated over and
over again and look there will be
but we invested in uber lyft
grab hola
quadi which became one of them we did
every ride sharing company on the planet
because we thought it was amazing
yeah all of those
will be displaced
by decentralized versions because
there's no reason
that when i got a ride to the airport
the other day up in chicago that 30 of
that money went to a centralized
organization just for writing code years
ago
no reason for that
now
will they decentralize themselves
probably not so somebody else will
probably create it but the hard part is
replicating the network effect so we'll
see
yeah i think it's essential to have an
open mind about all the different
protocols that are being built at the
moment um for me bitcoin is king um i do
believe it'll always be king especially
when it comes to being a sort of value
obviously as we've spoken about um but
i'm excited you know
who knows it's impossible to know you
know what's coming next um but just
finally um i want to ask you given
bitcoin has you know is down at 42k
today
where are we at in this cycle um a lot
of people um are calling for new
all-time highs i know jason williams is
calling for an all-time high the end of
october he loves the end of october so
where do you stand on this or are we
heading out into a bear market and pop
and i
had a little debate about this this
morning
okay um
look i i hope they're right
okay i do caveat that with hope is not
an investment strategy it's actually a
four-letter word so hopefully not a good
thing to hang your hat on
and and jason has very good reasons for
why he thinks that's going to happen uh
as does pomp um
look i
i believe that
predicting the future is impossible to
your point and that like soros said you
should think in scenarios
not in single points so
i believe the range of outcomes this
year
looks actually pretty bell curved
normally i would say the distribution of
outcomes in in bitcoin is skewed to the
right
right it's not a perfect bell curve it's
it's skewed to the right and it's
heteroscedastic meaning that there's you
know more right-tailed and left toe risk
okay
that said
um
i think right now
i think we're pretty bell-shaped i think
there is a
low probability that we
bust through the
4000 and make trip and make quad digit
and
and the reason i believe that's a low
probability is i
i unfortunately
have probably convinced myself that
if you go back in time and you say oh
this is just a four year cycle that has
to repeat
okay
totally logical yes with one flaw
in 2009
cycle repeated john 13 cycle repeated
2017 cycle repeated
um so why is it different this time
2009 13 and 17
everyone wasn't looking at the same
model
right number nine there were no models
2013 there were no models 2017 there was
the one
parabolic trav model i don't think he
actually even made it some other guy
made it but it basically showed the
metcalfe's law parabola and then
um
canine crypto uh did his version tim
peterson did his version there was a
lower trajectory because he had a
different decay rate and his actually
been much more accurate so then
uh 100
100 trillion came along and love him
love his work
but here's the problem
is
everyone was looking at that model and
everyone including myself was convinced
that on july 15 of this year we were
going to hit a hundred thousand and then
we were likely going to have that
parabolic blow-off that you know max
kaiser and and jason and all the others
were saying we're going to 200 or 220 or
250.
totally logical it's exactly what
happened in 2017 totally logical we hit
100 i mean we hit the 10k
six days after the model said
and within five weeks we were double
that because that's when the speculators
come in and the greed pushes price above
value
then we crashed because we didn't have
any way to custody it right and we had
to build out the custody and we had to
get the institutions and so we went all
the way down to six and then went all
the way down to three
and so here we are we hit 64.
i unfortunately believe that whether it
was michael bury
or someone else like him
i might even posit that
elon himself might have been short who
knows
but um
somebody got short and they got short in
size and they triggered what we're
talking about at the beginning of this
there were way too many people with
hundred times leverage
1.7 million liquidated
liquidated and boom we're down 55
percent
then liquidation stop
some institutions come in and buy again
whether that was elon buying or others
but there were two big accounts 1.7
billion each buying um back in july and
were up 50 from that bottom back to the
low 40s
and so everybody's like oh we're back in
the bull market
possible
the problem is it's possible and i'm not
saying likely but it's possible
that
this cycle has been truncated because
too many people were looking at
the
uh stock to flow model
and that the rollover this time
was the top
and
then that means we're in an 18-month
bear pattern until the next and that
doesn't mean we have to go to 94
it just means we can be stuck here the
thing i'm most concerned about
and again it's not it's not a big
concern i don't lose sleep over it but i
am concerned about it
that no one that i know and i know a
decent number of people
no one i know
saw november
october november
uh 2018
six to three
no one i mean i'm sure somebody out
there saying i saw it i saw them like i
don't believe it um no one i know saw it
and why did that happen
supply and demand
i mean
you only get the parabolic moves when
people are buying on margin
there aren't enough new owners in size
and you know pomp has some very
compelling stuff that will put together
on the number of new
addresses on the chain
that came in
as of july this year very compelling
but the dollars aren't big and so
until
we
and here's the problem as i see it you
just had the three largest
uh
exchanges in the world
basically just told
we're gonna shut you down
now they didn't exactly say it that way
but they basically said even if you try
to operate outside china and come get
chinese money we're coming after you
so
look
finance or bonanza depending on how you
pronounce it uh i i've never heard
anything i say finance i just say
finance and i like hmm that's
interesting it's like insurance and
insurance but and then wobby and ftx
and fgx is moving to the us and they're
doing us but but there's still
a lot of it's china
and
still 20 of of volumes and whether that
dries up so if if that is shrinking
show me
the new
money that's entering
at a pace
that can cause a parabolic move
i hope it's there i would love to see it
and i'm working hard every day to try to
convince institutions pension funds
endowments
wealthy individuals that they should get
off zero
but it's still it's still tough so
that's a long answer leia that yeah it's
okay
i
i don't want to be
the boo bird right i don't want to be
the guy who says oh you know we're in
for a bear market
but
i think we're stuck right now
and
if
we get
incremental
buying power
um i do think that the free float
is
small enough
that we could and that's why i say
there's there's a small probability that
we could have that blow off
two
to six or to nine digits
but
we're six digits we need that
extension yeah six digits
we need that new money basically we need
we need a lot of new money it's in your
money and and look
we need the next billion right i did i
participated in this thing called the
coins podcast uh which is an awesome
thing
and
the guys did such a great job putting it
together when i say guys i mean guys and
gals um
but uh because it was guys and gals and
they did such a great job so well
produced so high quality all the you
know the ogs are there and and you know
i got to be there because you know i'm
i'm friendly with with patrick
and
it's awesome but it's for the next
billion right we need to get the next
billion
and i'll leave you with this it's so
funny so i got asked to speak the google
investment club a number of years ago
and uh google value investment club
actually and uh
so i go we're walking around the campus
with this group of of you know very
smart you know guys and they make so
much money that they want to invest in
value instead of putting it all on
google
and
i said so so how many people are on the
campus the one guy says oh you know 25
000. and the other guy says are you
kidding me there's 40 000. i said so
within 15 000 people you know how many
people are on this little campus which
not little
and i think that's the problem of of how
many users are there in bitcoin right
are there 100 100 million or they're 200
million
we know within
50 or 100 million how many there are we
don't know exactly so getting the next
billion
is really really important and that
takes you know tom and gisele saying are
you in right that's awesome and it takes
people seeing ads in the mainstream
media and it it takes something emerging
like godaddy did for the internet it
makes me know a website why do i do a
website
so um
all those things are important but
ultimately it goes to
uh need right when people need to opt
out
yeah no i'm actually surprised there
aren't more users in europe quite
honestly with negative interest i know i
would think everyone and their sister
would be
you know opting out for at least a
portion uh and taking money out of the
banks of course then they'd be
exacerbating the problem that the banks
would fight back against but uh we are
aware better than better than negative
interest rates yeah i'm with you i think
um need is actually a really important
point and that um in my opinion is sort
of the silver lining in the last 18
months that we've had you know whether
it's um inflation with more money
printing um whether it's um vaccine
passports and all these things you know
which really just come down to more
control greater control um
crypto for me bitcoin whatever you want
to call it um is kind of just like that
lifeboat and
um so many people have been red peeled
and orange peeled and all these sorts of
fun colors um in the last 18 months so
yeah i think you know um need
will be will be that will be the case we
see that in africa and latin america and
so on um you know the cool part is
it's inevitable
yeah uh it will take longer than we all
think or want but it's inevitable
because
it is superior technology it is solving
basic human needs
and and
the talent right
two things to do in investing follow the
money follow the talent and the talent
migration into this space
is like nothing i've ever seen and i've
been around a long time and i've seen
lots of talent migrations different
levels the internet was by far the
biggest best incredible
this is bigger
and
you know people who
you just can't believe
are leaving
their traditional jobs their traditional
world
and uh you just remind one last story
and i'll let you go no go for it yeah i
just did gas the digital assets summit
here up in new york uh last week or two
weeks ago i guess and um
two years ago was last time we did it
because the cove had lockdowns the
nonsense
and
it was the last you know live event i
did in november of of 19
and
uh i remember being up on stage doing
the closing keynote and and i finished
and you know i was doing my raw rod this
is you know what you should do and this
young guy comes up to me says hey
would you call my mom
like what he says well you were up there
saying that you know this is the
greatest talent migration and that we're
smart for going into this and my mom
thinks i'm an idiot i left this big law
firm and and it's amazing and i said
yeah let's call your mom so we called
his mom and said no your son is not an
idiot he's really smart and uh this is
big really big and
and uh you know i need to find out who
it was and meet him and have a beer and
and see how he's doing but
um i'm sure he's doing well and
it it is
it is one of those things where
uh
i love the people that i hang out with i
love doing stuff like this with you and
and the energy the enthusiasm the
uh the desire to to to make the world a
better place
right yeah you know you hear jimmy speak
and you're like man i'm gonna go save
the world you know i don't want to buy
bitcoin i want to i want to do more
yeah and there's so many people
and if we can make some money along the
way great that's good too
but there's so many other really
important things like reversing the
wealth and income inequality problem
that we have around the world like
raising more people out of poverty like
my personal pet peeve how can we have a
weight loss industry in the united
states where we spend 20 billion dollars
a year
and 10 million kids go to bed hungry
every night
that's unacceptable that's absolutely
unacceptable insane how can that be
that's because people don't spend time
on it and they think it's okay
and uh it's not okay and there are lots
of things that we can do
um
taking many of these technologies that
we're all working on to make those
things better and there are people
working on it and don't and i love and
admire all those and we support them
with our foundation and things like that
but
so much of
this fight and i said this is the fight
right first they ignore us then they
laughed at us now they're gonna fight us
and it's funny i saw a clip of myself um
from 2018 right after i formed morgan
creek digital i was on one of the
morning shows with maria i think
and she said so you know you've spent
all this time in the traditional world
and you know what are you going to do
now i'm like well
it's so funny because i was all suited
up and i looked really good i'm like man
i look like crap now i don't wear a suit
i wear this silly suits
suits are
but i i was looking pretty sharp and uh
and uh i had my orange tie on for
bitcoin
and i said look i'm gonna spend the next
two decades
uh tokenizing the world
nice and i was like wow and i look back
and i and i tweeted it out and
hashtagged it and and and look that's
what we're going to do we're going to
tokenize the world and
every asset in the world is going to be
tokenized all of it is going to drive
this trust net this internet of value
and is going to change everything
and
it's cool
it is cool um i think it's incredible
that as
things get harder in this world and
authoritarianism comes strong we have an
option to opt out we have um an option
to um and a method to make the world a
better place that's one of the reasons
why uh what really drew me um to this
industry was not so much bitcoin at
first but it was much like blockchain
technology
and you know banking the unbanked i
don't know that really excited me that's
always really excited me so 40 of the
adults in the world don't have a bank
account two-thirds of them have a mobile
phone and all of them
can
be
they can be self-sovereign and look
there are tons of amazing stories in my
my latest one i've been telling which i
think is just totally cool
is
uh
these
migrant farmers in southeast asia they
were getting paid literally like a
dollar a day to do really hard work
uh basically started doing axi infinity
and bought some axes and started
breeding the axes and they're now
selling them they're making now tens of
thousands
of dollars a year
instead of a dollar a day
and everybody says oh that's just such a
waste of time like are you kidding me
it is awesome it is an awesome example
of technology making people's lives
better and those people will become
better citizens and and i go back to
there was a time in the united states
where every
african-american
doctor or lawyer
in america was the son or daughter of a
pullman porter
pullman porters were indentured servants
they were owned by the railroad
okay don't like to talk we don't always
talk about that right they were owned
these people were owned by the road but
they all
saved up
and made better lives for the kids send
them to school got them educated and
eventually we had an african-american
president and that is
awesome right
and that's what's happening here is
we're seeing this technology
impact real people's lives around the
world
and
some might say well
what good
is an axie
well my son and i have had a lot of fun
playing video games together and we bond
over it and you know we teach i teach
them about business and
i don't know i i see value in it and i
think
that person's life
now is better and from that project
maybe they graduate to another maybe
actually they go back to school and
learn how to code and then maybe they
get a you know job and maybe they build
the next scaling solution who knows
um maybe that's a little fanciful but
it's not impossible
yeah no i'm with you um but mark i want
to thank you so much it's always so
fascinating um to speak with you we've
gone through so many topics more than
i'd expected so it's really amazing so i
really appreciate it thank you so much
for coming on now great to be with you
later we'll talk to you soon
all right guys and don't forget to tune
in next week for another brilliant guest
we'll see you then
[Applause]
[Music]